the experience of having everybody
around me on campus say you know the
lift is the way to go and then seeing
communism collapsing made me think you
know maybe the libertarians have a
better handle on how these things work
[Music]
hi I'm Nicolas be with Reason TV and
today we're sitting down with Todd
Seavey's a longtime writer blogger comic
book creator and now most recently he's
published a great book called
libertarianism for beginners Todd thanks
for talking to us thanks for having me
what is the basic definition of
libertarianism as you see it I would say
if I'm taking a consensus view of the
whole movement it's something like keep
the government small and let people do
what they want with their own bodies and
property and I have my own you know
quirky preferences about how the
movement ought to work but in the book I
tried to stay fairly neutral and
describe though yeah you walk through
all of the various schools from
anarcho-capitalist who you know will you
name it so it's all in there
this book is richly illustrated by
Nathan Smith and it is you know it's for
beginners who are you trying to reach
with this book and why do they need to
be reached people I guess who are
curious but aren't already steeped in
the movement so I imagine it'll appeal
to to people who already know about
libertarianism to some degree but I'm
hoping maybe they'll buy it and give it
to all their socialist friends maybe a
few professors or you know buy it for
their classes
if high school students read it probably
very happy also I guess right now
probably the movement is in flux to some
degree it seems like online there are
various little fragments and factions
fighting with each other a lot of the
time long crazy Facebook threads so this
is an attempt to give an overview even
as people diversify and perhaps end up
in their own weird little libertarian uh
you you had worked as a producer with
John Stossel at ABC News yes he's now at
Fox Business he wrote the forward to the
book and he said you know libertarian
ideas are really hard to get across the
people you did a pretty good quick
summary there thanks do you agree with
him and
and if so why is that the basic
principles of libertarianism are very
simple so I think there actually is a
good argument for sticking to the basic
idea that you own your body you own your
property
no one should mess with them at all if
you teach people that basic idea you can
always go back later and talk about you
know special cases or footnotes or
various qualifiers
but if you convey that basic idea you've
gone a long way toward convincing people
that burglars and governments are both
undesirable if you start in a more mushy
complicated way talking about how do you
preserve Social Security or yeah make
the government a little bit smaller or
something right or you know are there
ways to you know introduce more
incentives into local telecom
regulations or whatever it becomes a fog
gotta tell you I passed out there for
exactly a few of our wonky friends will
enjoy greatly and build whole careers on
but the average person is not going to
be attention yeah I know you went to
Brown University and you were years ago
I mean this is 20 plus years ago you
were a columnist that reason and I
remember Brown used to show up in your
work there what was what is your
libertarian conversion narrative did it
happen at college it did happen at Brown
and so that was right at the end of that
was right around the time the
aforementioned Soviet Union was
collapsing people sometimes forget I
think I would like to forget that back
in the day while the Soviet Union
existed the Marxists on campus were
rooting for the Soviet Union they
weren't just like vaguely
philosophically similar they were you
know they were kind of hoping it would
win the Cold War and then suddenly right
while I was in college the Soviet Union
collapsed and it was amazing to see how
all the professors at Brown were like
changing the wording of their courses so
that instead of being socialist
perspective on the reality it was
suddenly a postmodern perspective or an
environmental perspective they all had
to scramble to come up with a new
explanation but I was reading stuff like
a recent magazine and Adam Smith and I
in Rand on the side for the most part
because those things weren't in my
classes at Brown while I was surrounded
by Marxists so the experience of having
everybody around me on campus say you
know the left is the way to go and then
looking out the window at current events
and seeing communism collapsing made me
you know maybe the libertarians have a
better handle on how these things work
is libertarianism on the rise you know
at reason we talk a lot about the
libertarian moment we talk about all of
the good things happening there
obviously you know drug legalization gay
marriage to a certain degree free trade
has won although it's under attack now
and then you know you have authoritarian
strains of both the Republican and
Democratic Party is libertarianism
winning over your twenty plus years of
being part of the movement just the fact
that the Soviet Union is gone is a huge
plus so I mean I already feel like to
some degree we're in the happy epilogue
after a horrible Twilight Struggle and
I'm just old enough that I'll always
feel like we won the Cold War so things
can't be too bad but right now it's very
hard to judge whether the next few years
will look more socialist or more
libertarian I'm sure a lot of us were
very optimistic a year ago when it
looked like Rand Paul might actually be
the leading nominee for the Republicans
and now it's Trump who criticizes global
trade once tariffs sounds like sort of
an authoritarian and the Democrats who
twenty years ago we're turning into
neoliberals of some sort
are now in love with Bernie Sanders
who's an explicit socialist so hey you
know some trends were improving but
there are very scary things in
mainstream politics fascism still exists
even if it's Underground and socialism
certainly exists and I don't know what's
going to happen next and increasingly I
think if within a century it's not going
to matter because the robots will kill
us all and on that happy note we will we
will conclude this interview we have
been talking with Todd Seavey he's the
author of an excellent new book
libertarianism for beginners it's got a
great foreword by John Stossel it's got
fantastic illustrations by Nathan Smith
Todd thanks so much for talking to us
thanks for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]
you
[Music]